bravely second end layer is a sweeping
adventure across Celtic myths pirate
legends and science fiction fairy tales
poor writing and forced plot points do
impede the journeys momentum but it's
vivid world and sleek combat are strong
enough to overcome the weight dragging
it down
as a sequel to 2012 bravely default and
lair returns you to Lux and dark a land
of arid deserts and snow-capped
mountains throughout your travels you'll
upgrade for characters engage in
turn-based combat
earn new specialist classes and prevent
the world from crumbling around you the
story serves mainly as a means to pull
you between Lux and darks locales
offering new MacGuffins on a whim as you
navigate class struggles and solve a
variety of political disputes along the
way nobody important we're just looking
for a man named go go ah go get it the
new guy at first and layers variety is
suspect it's hard to tell whether it's a
wild Western a medieval journey or a
dystopian sci-fi drama but after several
hours it's clear the game is using the
gamut of genres to introduce aesthetics
and characters just for spectacles sake
at this point I'm content to let unfold
curious as to what I'll see next and
layers characterization and dialogue
don't reflect the same ambition though
in fact its main character a young
Cavalier named Eugenie Olga is cloying
from the start his catchphrases arrive
during emotional moments his reactions
to plot twists are rarely believable his
optimism and candor remains static
throughout never drawing any real
meaning from his sense of innocence in
naivete few of n layers characters
display much dynamism but U is the
embodiment of the poor writing choices
that drag the adventure down and layer
also breaks the fourth wall several
times throughout often during pivotal
plot moments and it feels forced
every time these meta moments which I
won't spoil here are interesting
concepts on their own but the story
doesn't earn them they cheapen what
little drama the writing already
struggled to impart capture everywhere
can't see everything and what they see I
see
while n layers narrative fails however
its combat succeeds the turn-based title
brings back the brave and default system
established in its predecessor by
defaulting each character enters a
defensive stance and saves up brave
points which allow them to use multiple
actions in one turn do this without
defaulting though and you're useless for
the next several turns and layer
benefits from this risk reward system
much like bravely defaulted there's an
inherent tension when choosing between
careful defense and all-out aggression
but now eponymous bravely second ability
also reprises its role the mechanic
allows you to stop time granting one
character an extra action during that
turn further increasing the possible
ability combinations against your
enemies it's especially useful against
tougher bosses where each turn carries
more weight than it might otherwise and
all of this combat is built on the
franchise's recurring job system jobs
and the array of possibilities
surrounding them are bravely seconds
lifeblood as with the game's varied
locales its class system borrows from a
plethora of genres there's a Templar
there's an exorcist there's even a cat
person there are 30 jobs in total and
each character can equip two at a time
by combining the passive abilities of
one with the active attacks of another
you can create your own disparate
subclasses to further your goals and
layers class system is as much about
experimentation as it is execution
actually acquiring each available job
however leads to problems in n layers
overall structure although many classes
are unlock through the main storyline
some are tied to optional side-quests
that pit to npcs against each other by
choosing sides in the conflict you opt
to fight the opposing character thereby
gaining their job for the remainder of
the game
this is conceptually intriguing but it
often creates situations where the job
you want is at odds with the character
you agree with n layer forces you to
play story above gameplay or in some
cases the other way around without
spoiling too much bravely second does
allow you to retrace your steps in order
to collect every job title in the game's
ladder half but the dissonance of the
earlier side missions halts the momentum
of the globe-trotting plot
on that note the sequels late game hours
are far more enjoyable than those of its
predecessor the pasting is constant
throughout here and you witness
different areas from those of the first
half it's a far cry from the
backtracking and tedium of default
waiting chapters despite end layers new
quests though and the variety of locales
and display here it's worth noting how
familiar the sequel can seem as a whole
for large chunks of the game you're
revisiting the same cities and dungeons
as those from bravely default and the
combat
despite its sleek design doesn't make
any major improvements on the
well-established formula these
complaints don't affect end layers
overall quality but considering the time
the first installment took to beat its
sequel imparts a sense of deja vu more
often than I prefer one can argue it
feels more like an exceptional expansion
than a true sequel but in the end
bravely second transcends the
limitations that its poor writing and
redundant storyline create it's a grand
adventure in every sense of the phrase
whisking you across exotic environments
and satisfying your curiosity every step
of the way it has its restraints but as
the story closes on the plains of Lux
and dark bravely seconds grasp more than
matches its reach we know when the enemy
will strike again
fisherman's ballbuster Magnolia arch